Yolanda is in San Diego hi Yolanda how
are you hi thank you so much for taking
my call how are you
better than I deserve what's up yes I
started your program back in February I
took FPU through my church and when I
started I was a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars in total debt I make a
hundred and thirty thousand a year my my
debt breaks down to I have a hundred and
nine thousand dollars in student loan
debt I have about thirty thousand
dollars of credit card debt about 21
thousand dollars of car loan debt I'm
really struggling hard with my budget
and and following the debt snowball
because I keep running out of money and
having to borrow from my emergency fund
just to make it through the month when
you stop stop where did you run out of
money well I have my emergency fund
saying I got that but where did you run
out of money I'm paying my bills off
stage okay well I'm sorry if you laid
out a budget and told every dollar where
to go before the month begins where did
you run out of money because I get paid
bi-weekly but you know that before the
month begins how did you run out of
money said you did you said I keep
running out of money and using my
emergency fund yes good knew know what
you always say that oh yeah so are you
like coming up short on food yes I'm
coming up short on actually just getting
the bills paid no you would have a bit
laid the bills out on penny are laid out
in right
I have a mala later so what is your take
home pay per week per paycheck you get
paid every two weeks yes how much is
your time on pay for a check I get about
thirty four hundred dollars bring home
on my check and I get about six hundred
and fifty five dollars of child support
so about four thousand eighty dollars
every two weeks then you've told me you
made a hundred and forty thousand a year
one hundred and thirty thousand so you
got a big tax refund I got about a total
of four thousand back in tax refund
which I used to pay off what I own in
federal tax from the year of 2017 so far
I've paid off about ten thousand dollars
of that in three months after starting
your program okay well you're currently
bringing home eighty eight thousand
dollars a year you make a hundred and
forty those numbers don't work or do you
have your 401 K still coming out I make
about a hundred and thirty thousand five
hundred and thirty okay yes I've done
all of my retirement contributions but
you shouldn't have a forty thousand
dollar tax bill even in California what
happened is the third year before I I
ended up in tax trouble because I cashed
out a retirement plan to have enough
money to put down on buying a house I
know now that was the biggest mistake I
could have made I didn't know about you
then they but now I know you and you're
like you know it's like we're having an
affair I listen to you all the time
driving the work at home i watch your
podcast and watching YouTube videos I
get encouraged daily by that's three
screams but right now I'm just getting
so discouraged because okay I want you
to hold on get done I'll have Kelly get
you with one of our coaches because
there's two major things going on here
that I'm hearing okay number one your
take-home pay does not add up with what
you're telling me you make you should be
bringing home more than ninety thousand
dollars when you make a hundred and
thirty even if you live in California
that's wrong there's something wrong
with the math okay and I want someone to
look into that with you that help you do
that
the second thing is you are not
budgeting enough for food you're kidding
yourself when you do your budget you
need to put more money in your food
category because you're coming up short
every month bills that are fixed bills
you shouldn't come up short on because
if you put $3,400 at the top of a
two-week period of time and you give
every one of those dollars an assignment
you shouldn't spend more than 3,400 on
paper for that two-week period of time
or 7000 for that for that to pay period
period of time for a typical month you
should not come up short because you
shouldn't plan to come up short the only
place you could come up short is if you
underestimated something like food or
you underestimated something like your
utilities and they came in higher than
you thought that would cause you to come
up short but you shouldn't be having any
reason to dip into your emergency fund
with what you've outlined for me and so
you have enough money coming in to pay
the bills that you outlined here unless
your house payment is outrageous and if
you bought into an outrageous house that
may be choking you down but even then
you can still lay out on paper exactly
what you're gonna do and every dollar
has an assignment and you would never
have a plan to come up short I'm
planning to come up short now you would
never do that and so that means you're
under estimating one of the categories
like food like you may need to put
several hundred dollars more on the food
category than you are now as an example
I don't know what you're doing
hold on I'm gonna have Kelly pick up
we're going to get one of our coaches in
the area with you one of our financial
coach Master Series folks with you to
help you look into those two issues
while your budgets struggling because
there shouldn't be and what's wrong with
your take-home pay cuz it's screwed up
some way or another